Bianeneos Rattlers, good morning.
Welcome. Thank you guys for being here
this morning. We have more people coming
in. Um, for those of you who don't know,
if you need a grown-up bathroom, there's
one like right across the hallway. Um,
but because none of you actually have
tags on your bodies, well, some of you
do, but not all of you. Just go to the
bathroom and come right back. There's no
lingering in the building. That is for
another time when you have an actual
batch. Um, so that's where the bathroom
is. It is only a oneperson bathroom. So,
no lining up. It's like the cockpit of
airport, like of airplane. Like we don't
have there's not a lot of room. So, uh,
one bathroom over there. Um, and then,
uh, there's coffee. I hope everybody had
a chance to sign in, but if you didn't
sign in, if you'll sign in on your way
out. All right. So, welcome, Benos. I'm
so glad you all are here this morning.
Um I want to thank you all for taking
time out of your day for a meeting to um
just kind of get some more answers or
get some some clarification and all the
things that are going on. Um I'd like to
thank the superintendent and everybody
that your posi everybody that came with
you today um for being here to support
us and um making yourselves available to
you know listen and answer questions. We
have 90 minutes for this meeting. Um,
a lot of it is going to be Q&A because
we opted not to do like the presentation
piece. I think a lot of
I think I think I'm over that. I mean,
we've seen a lot, right? I know there's
been some changes, but nothing really to
our our plan. So, I'm going to turn it
over now to Victoria O'Neal, who's now
the queen of Enroll Austin.
And it's already way better. Like, it's
just I think it's going to be a lot
smoother this year. All right, here we
go.
Good morning everyone. Um yes, no
presentation, but I do want to use um a
couple of slides to review um the uh
agenda and purpose and what we'll be
doing here today. Um thank you to
Principal Schultz for the welcome. Um
and we are um here to talk about um the
questions that y'all have um that are
specific to everyone here at Ridgetop.
Um so in terms of the uh norms for today
um we are all working together on the
same team to build the future for
education in Austin and um your students
in particular and so u if we can focus
on ideas and solutions um that will be
um that'll help make our time together
very productive. Uh we are asking
everyone including our um staff
responders who are kind of clustered
here at the uh start to um like try to
be succinct to honor the time that we
have. Um a lot of people have uh ideas
or um comments or questions that they
would like to share and so if we can
hold um to approximately one minute per
comment and then um for our uh district
speakers as well. Um and uh when we are
conversing with each other um maintain
respect as I know that this community
always does. If we can try to have one
speaker speaking at a time that will be
really helpful. And as we're doing the
Q&A um we are going to ask for um a
question to be shared. Uh it will be
responded to and then we do need to go
to the next uh person who has a
question. We want to make sure that as
many folks have a chance to share their
voice as want to. Uh and so um uh we ask
that you share the the things that you
would like to be addressed in your
initial statement so that way um we
don't have um a whole lot of follow-ups.
Um and uh while we are here we may
disagree on the ideas but we are all
assuming the positive intent and our
focus on our shared goal. Uh and um in
terms of um again the space and voice um
please keep an eye or keep your thoughts
open to the equity of voice and who um
has had an opportunity to speak and who
hasn't. And uh these are difficult
conversations and so we are coming
together with compassion, clarity and
honesty.
We do
espanol.
Okay.
Um
disposiv.
Okay. Thank you. Yes.
Okay. Um so, uh we do have um if we run
out of material in the room, we do have
some of your question cards that we
could address. However, um we think that
there probably will be um enough
conversation in the room. Um but we do
have those in reserve and uh our uh our
opportunity here today is to gain a
shared understanding of the changes and
um the rationale behind them and to gain
insights. We are always looking to
refine. There are always opportunities
to make things um better and um better
aligned with our goals and values. And
so, um, the ideas that have been brought
to us in all of the different settings,
uh, uh, whether it's been the comic
cards or in person, um, have been deeply
considered. Um, it doesn't mean that
every single idea is able to be
integrated, but I promise that we have
considered them. Okay. And now I'm going
to turn it over to our superintendent.
>> Thank you.
Um, so I appreciate y'all coming out
this morning. Uh, you know, it's, um,
this is what you want, right? You want
families, you want community that
engage, that support their schools. Uh,
and so I know it's a difficult
conversation. Um, but I will be here. We
will be here to answer any questions you
have. We may not have all the answers.
There may still be things that we have
to explore. Um, but I just want to just
share my sincere appreciation for you
all uh, showing up this morning. Um, I
know you're taking away time from other
things uh that you could be doing.
I also want to acknowledge just how hard
this is. Um,
this is hard. Uh, I know it's a
disruption. I know there's pain in our
community. I know that uh there is real
harm that we as a school district, you
as families are experiencing. Um, I want
to acknowledge it. I want you to know
that we as a team um cannot necessarily
um put ourselves in your seat, but many
of us and many of those in the
administration do understand and and I
just want you to know that we
collectively love our school district.
We do. Um I love this city. I love this
school district. I am doing everything I
can to ensure that we are who we need to
be as we move forward for the next 50
years.
And when we talk about what that means,
we've been um kind of sharing this
understanding of of a neighborhood
school. And it at Ridgetop, you have a
very strong neighborhood school. Um
there is no doubt. I've spent time here.
I have friends that come here. I've come
and read here. Trust me, I know how
incredible this school is.
I also want you to know that this does
not exist everywhere in Austin. Uh
that's the honest truth. it doesn't uh
much of it is because of decisions that
the district made years ago, decades
even. Uh but we simply do not have the
ability to ensure that every student
gets what they need to be successful.
And we know that every student needs
something different. And so we embarked
on this work. We really were focused on
ensuring that through this work and
multiple steps afterward, we would get
to a place where we did have strong
neighborhood schools everywhere in
Austin so that students and families
didn't feel like they had to leave their
neighborhood. You know, neighborhoods of
different sizes in different parts of
Austin to go but to go to a strong
school. And so I want to be really clear
and we're going to get into questions
and answers and I want to spend time
there, but I I want you to know kind of
the things that drove this plan. You all
heard them. I I know that you probably
know most of them, but I I think it's
worth just me saying what they were so
that when we talk about the complexity
of this plan, you can maybe see how it's
all woven together and why we arrived at
these
draft recommendations or draft plans.
The first is I desperately believe that
aligned feeder patterns are something
that this district has to address. I I
strongly feel that in my bones and I
think that many of our trustees do as
well. There's a reason that aligned
feeder patterns in certain parts of
Austin exist and have existed for
decades and where middle schools go
wholly into high schools. You see that
at Merkasen going wholly into Anderson.
You see that Henry going holy into
Austin High. You do not see that in East
Austin. You don't. You see middle
schools that go to three, four, and five
high schools.
And in order to disrupt that, it
requires a comprehensive boundary plan
and change. So that was one kind of
component of this work that we wanted to
address. The second thing is we wanted
to address transfers like our system has
is an amalgamation of just different
types of policies and operating
procedures over the last 20 years that
has led to kind of inequities in how we
manage transfers what policies we have
in place and we really had to address
that. It's led to some imbalances in our
system. It's led, you know, to different
families, you know, having different
avenues to to move through the system
and in many cases creating harm in a
neighborhood. And the again, these are
decades old in some cases. I want to
tackle transfers. Third thing, we wanted
to address the reality that the
enrollment in Austin has declined for a
very long time. It has. You know, at one
point, you know, a little over a decade
ago, we had 86,000 students. Now we're
just over 70,000.
We have about 20,000 extra seats in
Austin ISD. If you think about that,
that's about 3,000 seats greater than
the Moody Theater. It's a lot of seats
and they're not all in one area. I mean,
they're spread throughout the system.
So, it's not very easy for us to just
extract and find those seats. We really
have to think about the movement of
students, the movement of programmings
to ultimately reduce the number of of
empty seats.
The other thing that we wanted to tackle
is we had to address the um
accountability system that we're in.
Right? The 23, 24, and 25 accountability
coming out the way that it did put
extreme pressure on our system. If we do
not respond to the accountability system
and ensure that we break these
accountability chains,
then the risk of state intervention up
to right installing a board of managers,
which is meaning losing local control um
could occur. Now, our board and I am
committed to ensuring that doesn't
happen. And there are things that that
that I wish we had more time on, but the
reality is the state has their timeline.
They have the authority. They have the
power. We have to be responsive. And so
this plan attempts to kind of weave all
that into it so that we're finding
solutions where they might not otherwise
exist.
And the last component which I think is
pertinent to why we're here today um
again combined with others is alignment
within our programs our programs that
were built out within Austin ISD to um
support um access to different things
and we talk about dual language in
Austin ISD. It's something we believe
in. You'll often hear me see say how
important and how valuable I be I
believe being multilingual and
multicultural is in Austin ISD. We are
leaning into dual language when other
school districts around us are leaning
out.
But the reality is that some programs
whether it's wall-to-wall dual
languages, Monastery and others that we
have in the system have evolved over
time and without kind of reestablishing
kind of the core um student group to
ensure kind of long-term sustainability,
it will suffer. That is the honest
truth. And so when we looked at program
movement, we looked at positioning these
programs where access could increase for
those students who were originally the
focus of the program and the and the
focus of the program originally and
always will be are emerging bilingual
students. We value providing that access
to others but the core by policy by law
it's emerging bilingual students.
And so, um, those are the things that we
attempted to weave into this plan. Uh, I
do want to acknowledge there's been some
adjustments, uh, that came out yesterday
and timeline. We can talk about that.
Um, but the reality of it all is we have
to do something. There is no doubt. Um,
this plan is not perfect. No plan is. I
want to spend time with you. I want to,
you know, hear your thoughts and and
questions and share with you kind of our
responses and what we've learned through
this process and how we can improve. I
um just want you to know that we're
doing this in a very honest way. We're
we're really trying to find a solution
that works, but it doesn't mean that
we're going to avoid disruption. Um
that's just the truth. So, um I'm happy
to to start begin answering questions.
Um, I do we have a lots of folks in the
team. Uh, I've never heard us call a
posi before, but thank you, Cara. Um, it
it's it's there are lots of folks that
we uh that we in El Paso. Thank she is.
Um, so yeah, let's let's we can start
going. Um, do you have a there's I'm not
great at managing like hand raises, so
well, she'll Victoria will help.
>> So, I think we're kind of here and then
up and then we'll come back down.
>> Yep. Okay. So, one, two, three, four.
Yes. four in the dark jacket and then
we'll do another round.
>> So, we've done that before. It's kind of
um we want to make sure it's comfortable
for you all. Whatever you think makes
the most sense. We've done lines um that
that works for you all. What do you
think would be most helpful?
>> No lines. No one wants a line back
there. I've done lines lines earlier in
the week, but yeah, I don't want to Hey,
this is y'all's I don't I don't want to
misstep here.
>> Okay. Um, so I will just say that when
you have this microphone, this one is
quite quieter and so um, uh, please have
your put the microphone close to your
chin.
>> Uh, superintendent, thank you for being
here. Uh, I appreciated your summary of
some of the factors driving this. I
think I I'll speak for this whole room.
Uh, the richtop community, sorry, can
everyone hear me?
>> The richtop community has tried to be
extremely open to this. I think we have
been collaborative. I think we have
bought into your vision. That email last
night changed some things for this room.
>> Um,
look, I heard your vision. There's three
things I also heard from you that I did
not hear that you just said. The first
was that you would not be caving to
carveouts to the loudest, wealthiest
communities.
The second was sorry.
The second was that you were committed
to being transparent with us. The email
that came through last night included a
carveout for three of the loudest
communities. The email that came out
last night offered no explanation for
why that carve out arose. And the email
last night included a reference to
allegations that have shaped the plan
with no indication whether those
allegations might have influenced those
carveouts one way or the other or what
else they might have involved with this
plan. I have been I think people in this
room will tell you one of your strongest
advocates.
I feel
I feel personally embarrassed and let
down.
And I I would like to hear if you plan
to bring some of that transparency
you've been promising back and share
with us what happened and how we got
where we got last night.
>> YEAH.
>> So I I I very much appreciate um your
comment. So, I know many of you don't
know me well. Um, but there are some in
this room that do. And what I'll tell
you is that I am someone that believes
in process. I am someone that believes
in ethical,
transparent processes that lead to
outcomes. And we may not all agree in
those outcomes, but if we understand how
we got there and we did it with
integrity at every step along the way,
then I am going to support a plan. I
will tell you that um what drove the um
the change in timeline yesterday and
again it is a change in timeline. It's
not a change or a lack of of us moving
forward with the overall plan was a
recognition
based on things that were brought to me
and other trustees. Just to be clear, it
wasn't just Matias, you know, like it
wasn't me making a a decision in
isolation or recommendation in
isolation. I was steadfast and I I I am
100% prepared and ready to go if I
needed to make a vote on the 20th. But I
truly believe in process.
And when it became clear to me that
refinements of the process, not the body
of work itself, but the refinements,
right, the feedback that comes from the
community that requires time and energy
and resources to analyze
was perhaps not
being um
fully assessed in the way that I expect
to make an informed decision. I had to
slow it down because community voice is
too important. Uh when it comes to
refinement, it it it just it I I see
there's lots of heads shaking and I
understand that. But when it comes to us
being able to make changes and
refinements to the plan, I have I have
to take that in, spend the time, make
the adjustments, and move forward.
You you said something about the light
loudest voices. There are loud voices
everywhere. There are loud there. There
are lots of people all the time sharing
with me their ideas, their perspectives.
They love their communities and there
are still voices and still communities
in this plan that are moving forward
that you know maybe others would say are
are are vocal. Um so that did not drive
this. What truly drove the change in
timeline was being able to protect the
process with the utmost integrity.
That's what drove it. I will never ever
be part of something that doesn't ensure
that that we got to the end and I felt
comfortable for how we got there. Um, if
that was the case, I think you'd see a
different plan. That's not what you saw.
You saw those schools that were not tied
to programmatic moves, that were not
tied to turnaround plans, that were
truly a function of balanced enrollment
and included Palm other schools, not
just the schools that I think you're
referencing. And I said, you know what,
those based on what we're hearing from
the community, based on what has been
shared with me regarding the concern of
us doing the work, I need to slow those
down. Um, with everything else, the
boundaries as well. So, so that's what
happened. That's the honest truth. Um,
there's there's not a single bone of my
body that doesn't believe that we have
to get there in a ethical like pro way
with integrity. I just I'm not going to
support a plan that doesn't do it. So
that's what happened.
>> I I don't I I what what part of the
question what specifically do you want
to know? It wasn't about loud voices
because there are other loud voices
tomorrow.
>> So when it comes to so this is the way
it works. This is what I I tell
individuals and I tell communities if
there are um ideas and um plans that
move us towards our goal, right? And do
not just say no because there are lots
of question there's lots of ideas about
just don't do this or how about this
other plan or how about this and I will
sit here and I'll tell you yes I can
support that no I can't support that to
the extent I can support that something
I can then do the analysis to to
progress it forward that is that is how
this is supposed to work um when it
comes to this community and and all the
communities we have been getting
feedback I know we haven't had this
meeting and we'll have this meeting and
we'll take the feedback but we have this
is not the only time we've gotten
feedback in this community. We we have
been listening. Y'all have been sharing
y'all's feedback and and we have been,
you know, trying to adjust, to refine
it, to take it forward.
>> The other schools, you're telling us you
couldn't get their feedback.
>> No, I I'm not saying that I couldn't get
their feedback. I'm saying that once
ideas became once different strategies
are made aware, shared with me, that
required due diligence and time to
explore them. I didn't have Oh, go
ahead. I didn't have the asurances that
each of those ideas, the ones that I
felt could be explored, were being
explored to meet my expectation. That's
the honest truth. I know it's not I mean
I I know you're saying you're not
answering the question, but that's
exactly what happened. And that's it.
>> Um I I trust me, I I just want you to
know I'm not alone in this. Like it
wasn't I I can't share
There there are there I I I am someone
who really strives to be transparent. I
really I really do. There are lots of
things um there's as you saw in the
letter there there are things or
investigations there are things
occurring right now. I'm not going to
speak more to it um regarding like the
examples or ideas. I will share with you
that
I I strive to do this the right way and
and in the moment that I think that
there is any aspect of it and again not
the full body of work but any element
within it that isn't
>> um progressing in a way that meets my
expectations I have to slow it down and
and that's that aspect of the work is is
what happened.
>> I mean that's us to trust you but you
broke our trust.
I I I the way you lose trust is by doing
something that I think is um not in
alignment with who we are in values and
and I am I am the person who's
responsible for ensuring that this
process is done that way. I mean I I
don't I never want to look back and I'm
sorry that I've lost your trust. I mean
I I don't want to build trust back but I
I just 70,000 students there there's a
lot happening. This this had to occur in
this way.
>> You haven't said anything.
>> I'm sorry you said
So, um we'll we'll move on to two and
and three. Um
there I I I would like to acknowledge um
that there are some things that are in
process right now that are not
disclosable. Um and so that what we're
running up against to is I think against
those boundaries. And so um that's why
That's why we have a policy.
>> All right. All right. Can everyone hear
me?
>> Okay. I think I'll help you with the
answer earlier. You changed the plan
because it's what can get the votes by
the board.
Um,
>> and then I think how I guess I
appreciate being a little bit more
honest about what this conversation
really is about and that's insulating
the ISD from state takeover. How
confident are you that you actually
extract this pain and we're not in the
same situation five years from now and
the state takes us over anyway? And
second part, does the board really
deserve our confidence anyway?
>> Yes.
I think
>> Okay, sorry about that. Um,
does does I will speak for Matias who
has daughters in Austin ISD who loves
this school district more than I mean I
I just I love this school district. Uh,
yes. I you our trustees deeply deeply
deeply care for this school district. Um
I will tell you that I have observed
other school districts. You see them all
around us. You see how they work. Our
trustees are philosophically aligned.
>> They may disagree and how we get there,
but they are all focused and ensuring
that your students get what they need to
be successful. I mean I I I I work with
them closely. And I promise you that
what you do not want is someone taking
that local control away from you. It's
happening right now in Fort Worth. It is
brutal. It is absolutely brutal. And
this is not about risk like state
takeover. That is an aspect. I have to
have to think about all of it together.
That is an aspect of it. I want to be
honest with you. But budget budget is
also a big part of it. Now budget does
ultimately if you go down a path too far
then that could introduce a state
takeover risk. All of it. I mean
technically if you go far enough
ultimately could be that. Um but I just
want to be really really clear like I
believe in this board. This board works
really hard. They're unpaid. They care
and there are many many examples over a
thousand examples in state of Texas
where you don't have that. So I I I just
want you to know like they are working
hard. Um I trust them. I trust them to
lead the school district whether it's me
as a superintendent or someone else.
That's the honest truth.
um when it comes to uh the plan I don't
want to be here again we are here
because of indecisions over the last 20
years
I mean it's been like disruption after
disruption since 23 even before that I
mean I can't it's it's not possible for
us to thrive and focus on the important
when everything is urgent which is what
it's been for the last four years
pandemic sure that happened to everybody
but then we went through three
superintendents in a year and a
executive leadership changes, principles
turnover. You had 20 over 24 principles
hired in one year. That's a quarter of
your principles just about
that instability like has a cascading
impact and it impacts our students in
the classroom. I think a correlation
between superintendent and principles,
principles and teachers, it's
understood. It's Dr. Matthews does all
the research on it and we've seen us
recover,
right? I mean, you look at early
literacy, early numeracy, everything is
moving in the right direction. We've
done so much in the last two and a half
years and we've tackled the TA greed
order. We've tackled a tax rate
election. We've tackled these these
pressures from the state. I am
desperately trying to take this next big
step and it may be a two-face step now.
And that's the honest truth. But it but
it we've been around for 144 years.
We're going to be be around for a very
for a lot longer. Um I do believe that
this plan reduces the overall risk as a
system. It doesn't mean that we won't be
back here having hard conversations, but
I do believe at this moment, given the
work that we've done, it will reduce
that risk significantly. Um, you know,
and I will say that if the state of
Texas wanted to already take an action
against AISD, they've had avenues to do
it. The the what I would say is there is
real evidence that we are moving our
systems, but we're doing it our way.
That's the honest truth, right? I just
gave you a couple data points that
demonstrate that the outputs are moving
and the outcomes are following. They see
that we understand that and that has
given us more time, more time, more
improvement, more growth. You had 30 Fs
and 23. You had 29 and 24. You have 23
and 25. You'll have a fraction of that
this coming year, right? And much of
that was was done was produced by a
system that be was predated our trustees
and me. So I I I do feel strongly this
this does move us in the right direction
significantly.
>> Uh thank you for being here.
>> Um first thing is if one part of the
process uh is broken isn't the entire
process broken and why not halt the
entire thing until you're 100% confident
in the whole process?
>> Yeah. So it's not the whole
So you heard me earlier talk about
refinement, right? Um we we because of
the size of this effort, we had to roll
something out that impacted 116 schools.
Uh the reality is when we get feedback,
whether it's a boundary change in one
part of Austin or a programmatic change
in one part of Austin, I am committed to
doing the work to ensure that those
refinements are considered, evaluated,
and we take the next step and I can
support it or not. That's the honest
truth. So the whole thing, no the
refinement. So this compression that's
occurring right now um when it comes to
some of the elements within the plan
require just that type of work and at
scale um I couldn't ensure that every
aspect that was brought to us by
community was fully evaluated to where I
could support it or not.
>> Okay. If we do continue with your plan
two questions should be real quick. Uh
when our family chose Ridgetop, we chose
it because the incredible leadership and
the teachers. We have not been
disappointed. The relationships with the
principal and staff are a big part of
what makes this uh campus so special.
>> So as we talk about the consolidation,
can you please share more details about
who will be leading the pickle campus
and what the staffing plan will look
like? Yeah. specifically is Miss Schultz
going to be our principal and are
current teachers going to be uh
transitioning over to pickle as well?
And then
>> let me just say the second question and
then you can kind of wrap it in one. Uh
we've been hearing a lot online about
the news words like gentrification,
colonization and have been coming up
when talking about pickle. Uh those are
hard words to hear and they reflect real
community fears. Uh if the heartwarming
it was heartwarming to see Pickle
Elementary highlighted during your
inspire the future lunchon. Um it
reminded us of the strong leadership and
supports that exists for students there.
>> We know Pickle currently offers a food
pantry, clothing pantry, mental health
supports and several community partner
services. My question is will those
services remain at the school for all
students after the consolidation and the
students whose families choose to attend
another campus will similar supports be
available for them at their new schools?
>> Yeah.
>> So that's a fivepart question. Um I'm
going to I will answer it. Uh, so I'm
going to first say when it comes to um
hiring, right, I I've been really clear
and because I don't want anybody to to
leave this room thinking that at any
point along the way, did this
administration, did myself ever consider
doing some type of like layoff. Like
there was some comment like months ago,
Matias is going to lay off 700 people.
Like that's ridiculous. Like that is not
who we are. That's not what we're about.
Our board and I are very much aligned.
And fortunately for us, for our size,
given how many staff we hire every year,
we're very able to absorb and move stu
staff around if there's a need to. And
the reason I say if there's a need to is
because when you have transitions like
Ridgetop to pickle and we um are
anticipating, right, uh that we will
have to we will name a principal at at
the new campus. That'll be done in
December. That'll be my decision to
make. Name that principal. It's done
strategically at that time so that we
can quickly identify the staff right who
need to support the new campus. Whenever
you have campuses coming together it is
my intention to ensure that our students
have familiar faces right that our
students and families understand who is
going to support their students and who
best than who was at the program that
where the students last were. Uh so that
is our overall strategy that I have had
conversations with our principles. Cara
and I have had lots of conversations. Um
those are between her and I. Um she's an
incredible leader. I want her in Austin
ISD. I think she's amazing. We have
amazing staff. I want all of our staff
in Austin ISD. How it will look will be
a a blend. I can't tell you
proportionality like you know what
percent it'll be because I want also
students who are at pickle emerging
bilingual students to see stu familiar
faces there also. but they also will
have other opportunities in the area.
So, um just I can't name who the
principal is going to be because that is
a conversation and a process that will
take place. It is obviously tied to
talent strategy and human capital. Um
but where you want to go is where I
would like to be. It's just that there's
a process we have to go through. Um I I
want our staff to be supported in this
transition, which is why time matters.
Um, in our documents that we've
uploaded, I'm not sure if anybody has
spent time with them, we talk about the
milestones in December, hiring staff,
making sure that we place everybody tied
to the staffing plan of those schools
first. Make sure that we're very
thoughtful for anybody that's going
through transition. If someone wants to
leave and go to a different part of the
school district, we will allow for that.
We will support them in that journey. We
will not hire a single person outside
Austin ISD until April. That is really
in an effort to protect our staff. Um
but yes, to your point, what I think you
envision is something that I would like
us to pursue. Um I just can't give that
certainty at this point because we don't
have a timeline and and that's Cara and
I talking and and getting through that
process. Uh the second part of that
question um was around I I have it back
my what was the second part?
>> Services
>> supports for students at
>> services. Yeah. So one of the things we
talk about is uh we want to make sure
that the services are meet student need
like we don't place services just you
know because they there's an open space
we really try to identify what are the
needs of the community if we need a
pantry we create a pantry so those
services will continue on um at that
campus uh based on student need. Now if
student need changes and the leadership
and the community says hey this is
something that is different now than it
used to be and we want to look at it
differently we will follow your lead um
but we will want to ensure that in
communities that need more support we
provide it. Um so it it's not like a we
will provide it but again it is going to
be part of the transition plan as we
move forward. We've been really really
clear like we have to get the
communities together. We have to plan
what the school is going to include and
then commit to having it be there. So if
a majority of the students here go over
to pickle and drown out the people who
actually need the services then those
services will leave. No, because when
you say drown out, um I I I think what I
would would say is we want we are
inviting and we are welcoming pickle
families and and our students there,
right? The goal is to move the emergent
bilingual student population, right? And
increase the percentage and to do that
we're providing transportation, right?
We made that change in the plan. We we
are we are wanting to ensure access.
It's a larger campus. We have lots of
flexibility in how to support both
student populations. I think that's one
of the things that's really really
unique about this plan um that you don't
see in perhaps other elements elsewhere
given the size of the campuses. Uh we do
not want any school community to not
feel welcome in the building they were
previously at. Um but I also want
Richtop to feel welcome and feel seen
and that's where the planning comes in.
Like we got to get everybody together
and begin a plan together. I we've done
this with Norman Sims. We've done it
with Mets and Sanchez. We have things
that we've done in the past that we've
learned from. We also have things that
we've we learned that we know we
shouldn't do and so we're incorporating
that into this process as we move
forward. It'll it'll really be a
combined effort.
Of course,
hi, I'm a neighborhood parent. Shout out
who's all neighborhood parents out here.
>> Thank you all for coming out.
Uh, so it was a great leadin question to
my question, which is Principal Schultz
has already communicated that she's
going to pickle. We all know this
already.
>> Yeah, we heard this early on. But look,
look, look, look, it makes sense. A
strong bilingual dual language teacher
going to a new dual language school
makes sense. And via survey, we know
that the transfer students who families
will follow her if she goes there, which
makes complete sense for them. And I
agree with you. You should. For
neighborhood families who want a strong
neighborhood school, who want to be able
to walk their kids to class, we're kind
of left out in secondass citizenship
here. So since our community is already
being torn apart, we have 60% transfers.
There's 40% remaining. It's already
ripped up. So, let's rip off the
band-aid. Why won't AISD allow
neighborhood families who are zoned to
this school to have priority choice to
go wherever we want in AISD rather than
going to an unknown rebuilt campus with
a new school but without the resources
to rebuild that school like a tip or a
tap school would have gotten.
So um so not to necessarily transfer
with ridgetop right community anywhere
um
>> otherwise
>> well well so that would be
>> so okay so you we're talking about
vertical teams and different schools now
so let me talk let's talk about this one
let's talk so let's talk about year one.
>> Okay. So, so is that something we could
consider for a transition period? Like,
you know, let's say that the rising um
fourth and fifth graders, right? Like if
you're in first, second, and third, you
know, fourth and fifth um you know,
could we create a a transition plan for
those neighborhood families who choose
not to go to Riley and choose not to go
to uh Pickle, right? Um I I think that I
don't know that that's something we
couldn't do. Um I I if if it's clear
that we're not if you choose Clayton,
right? I mean, you choose some school
that's really far away, I really clear
like we're not going to be able to we
can probably provide access, but we pro
we can't provide transportation because
a lot of times the question becomes, you
know, will you provide transportation?
Um I I don't I want to make this
transition
better, right? And I know it's in these
types of ideas if we can do them, we
will. So that is a good Let me I can
talk to Victoria about that and see what
we can do. We can make those types of
adjustments. I will say it can't be done
in perpetuity, right? So, um would have
to figure out kind of what timeline is
appropriate for the transition to occur
in and then obviously once you get into
the school then you're kind of a
tracking transfer and then you're you're
kind of set. But but I I I want to
acknowledge that and that is something
that we can we can probably work on and
um and figure out.
>> Yeah, of course.
>> I don't know who is next. Victoria, are
you keeping me?
>> So, we had I was I was pondering. Um we
had our last set and so um we can do one
two three four and then five sunglasses
on your head and then we'll um do
another round.
>> Who is one?
>> Hi, good morning. Um I'm also a
neighborhood family. So I have a
question about Lee. So in the most
upto-date revision, the sixth grade
program from Lee was removed. So my
question is about a boundary change.
Would it be possible for Austin ISD con
to consider allowing all of Hyde Park to
be zoned to leave so that we can stay
with our neighborhood friends and
rebuild our community? I understand a
guiding principle of the program was not
to split up communities, but we that's
happening for us. We support the dual
language program going to pickle, but my
part of my value system for my family is
the walkability of in these cherished
years with my children to walk them to
school, to bike to school. So, while I
have loved everything about this school,
it's the location that's most important
for me. And I would really love Austin
ISD to consider the impact on not just
the programming and the friends and the
building that ridgetop zone families are
losing, but we are also losing our
walkability because it is not safe to
get to Riley.
>> So,
um I just want to make sure I'm I'm I'm
hearing right. So, give me the um the
area. Not are you not saying the full
ridgetop?
>> Yeah, I just want to make sure I capture
>> zone
amilies
consider
all of this
true priority for those of us who are
experiencing an enormous amount of
change. So I'm asking
if I would like to understand if that's
not possible why not.
>> Yeah.
>> And then go from there.
>> Yeah. I think um
so so Lee Lee is also not empty. Um you
know the it depends on the number that
we're because it always comes down to
assumptions right and that's what we run
into all the time. Matias, you know,
there there are this many families that
are going to choose to leave Alson ISD.
There are this many families that are
going to choose to go to pickle. There
are this many families that are going to
choose to go, you know, perhaps to a
different school. Maybe it's a different
school that this gentleman said here
elsewhere in the in the network. Um I I
think we can from the transfer
perspective, I think that's workable.
Once we identify a school, I then have
to create an assumption and protect the
space at that school. uh sixth grade
coming out of Lee isn't a huge number of
of students, right? It's actually quite
small. Uh which is one of the reasons
we're we're actually pulling it all
together. It's one of the only schools
that has it aside from Blazer, which was
designed to have it many years ago. Um
we tried sixth grade in East Austin once
middle schools were impacted with Martin
and Mendes. It didn't go well. We are
just not set up um to to have provide
that experience and support our sixth
graders in that way. Um, so I think if I
think we can probably do this I on the
transfer priority. I I worry about
naming a school only because then now
I'm going to have to guarantee seats
which means that it may impact kind of
their capacity and then any other moves
that will come, you know, with boundary
changes moving forward. So I I hate to
get so far to commit now. think priority
transfers and say, you know, because
this school is going through a
transition, could we um support the
transfer process in a way that um kind
of meets your expectation without
defining a full school? I worry about
just saying everybody who's here can now
have this school or this school that's
outside of the original thinking without
saying the whole. So, I'm I think that
might be something we could do, but I
couldn't name le.
>> Yeah, exactly. And I just wanted to um
sorry to interrupt you, sir. Uh I just
wanted to say that um these are uh
valuable ideas and perspectives that we
will definitely go back and and discuss.
Um but without like really digging into
the data and understanding all of the
implications, right? Like we we just
can't make commitments here today. The
commitment is that we will write them
down and that we will have discussions
and we will figure out um you know the
limits of what is possible in the
interest of uh serving as many people as
possible. So just clarify
what the boundary look
which I believe is technically defined
as 51st Street.
>> Yes. So we have a working group that um
it looks at all of the um all of the
boundaries and has modeling software
that you know you click this and this
happens and you click that and that
happens. Um and uh so that is something
and um in further discussions on this um
we can uh we have been uh dedicated to
if we have to um say no or make
adjustments or anything like that to
explaining why. Um so we will continue
to have that commitment.
>> Yeah. And I think um you know we we are
working
>> so so when we talk about um so
walkability right not all schools have
walkability. I mean that's just the
honest truth. I mean with you know I
just just to be clear you have it here
doesn't exist everywhere. There are some
schools that are complete opposite. No
one walks everybody buses in because of
just where that that school is. So we
want to take the local contextual like
under understanding of the community and
make adjustments. Um so so walkability
isn't a factor until we get to school
level and then we say okay what
adjustments we need to make to ensure
the community is heard we're responsive
to the unique aspects of the community
in this case walkability. Um a 290 a
large highway that's a hazardous
intersection. We would provide
transportation across it. Uh that's part
of our standard policy. because we're
moving boundaries, they're going to be
new um routes that previously weren't on
um our approved list because those
intersections weren't part of that
school. Now they are. So um I would say
yes, but only in the local context. It
wasn't, you know, because it's a
walkable because you have schools that
are completely opposite. Um but yeah,
that's how we'll analyze it.
>> Do not even would be considered to have
>> I called in number two
that might be
>> hi. Um I'm also a zone student and I
just really want to reiterate that um
there is no plan for Riley that local
families we've been um I think really
uh
reasonable in our asks that all we want
is for AASD to acknowledge
that Riley is a really unique situation.
It is
>> and that you guys are paying attention
to us
>> and that you are going to provide Riley
extra support.
>> Yeah.
>> And like
>> I'm sorry I'm getting upset about this
because
>> like um
the email that went out last night told
me that we should have been unreasonable
in our asks. That's what I heard.
>> That's not the
So um
>> soision,
>> so um thank you for sharing that. So,
uh,
my response is I I apologize for, um,
not being as intentional around, uh,
kind of the structure of Riley and and I
I will say that um, no, I it's
I also I also want to kind of share with
you that we have from the from the
district's perspective other schools
that are restarting, right? And I I I
also wanted to have conversations with
the leadership at the campuses, right?
because you have to think about Riley,
right? And Riley's move, you know, that
principal um will have a decision to
make or not make and that will largely
inform kind of what the starting point
is for that campus, right? I mean, and
that's just the honest truth. And so you
you're right, Riley's in a very unique
situation. It's the only school that
that is having a programmatic move that
um we'll still have a neighborhood
school reside once that move occurs. And
so you actually have I think we have a
unique option um in Riley because
the way that I kind of think through
this is Riley educators and
administrators many of them but not all
of them will go to Wooten. You know
Ridgetop administrators
um staff many of them but not all of
them will go to pickle. So the the the
best place, you know, regionally and
from a community perspective to have
them come together would be the Riley
Neighborhood School. That that's just
that's that's but I can't I can't like
that is how I am thinking about it.
That's so we are spending time on the
back end but I can't share those steps
because we don't have a vote. We don't
have the principal but that is what I
would expect to happen. Um, and so what
I can do, um, after this conversation is
kind of share with you the thought on
the back end that we've put into Riley
that we haven't shared outwardly because
I I don't want to get ahead of like
these things that are very prescribed,
which is like votes, principal hirings,
those sorts of things. Because as soon
as I say that, the question is like,
well, is the assumption that Riley
principal is leaving or not leaving? Um,
so, so that's a tough spot, but I I will
commit to providing more information
around how we are thinking that'll work
because I want families at Riley and at
Richtop to have familiar faces at their
neighborhood school. That was the
objective the entire time. I'm sorry.
>> Well, because there there actually when
it comes it will you need the T. Yeah,
we we've we've thought through that. We
we will
we'll we'll
Yeah, there's we need our educators. We
It will work.
>> So,
>> so I I appreciate that comment and I'm
I'm sorry. I I could have done a better
job because we also have other schools
that are restarting,
>> but they're under um uh TAP, right? So,
it's and so they get more money, they
have more resources, they get more
support, and we feel like we get
>> you're not any transition is going to be
supported by the district. That that's
the honest truth. Like, we have a plan.
We're going to execute the plan. That is
where you will find me be steadfast.
Like when it comes to plans, where we
have failed as a district in the past is
implementation. We're great at making
plans. For decades, we've been making
plans, but it implementation. So I I
want to be hyper thoughtful, which is
why the timeline matters delaying into
the spring or delaying like I mean the
it's not going to help transition. It
won't. I want to spend the time thinking
about supporting our students,
supporting our staff, and getting it
right because it does have to happen.
Like we do have to go through this
evolution as a school district. So I on
on the transition planning um I wanted
to
um share like the pre-planning right so
all of this because it has been um a
really reflective process where there
have been adjustments along the way um
you know there have been adjustments to
um the transition enrollment plan there
have been adjustments to um specific
boundaries that between the releases um
there have been a lot of adjustments and
so um as we are planning for um any sort
of transition. Uh we have been mindful
not to lock things in too quickly uh in
order to um be responsive to those
transitions. Right? So um there has not
been a full transition plan released
because if we released it with the first
plan, then it would have had to be
completely revamped for the second plan
um and and you know and then would
continue to have um changes happening
even now. So, but um we those
conversations and those um items uh have
been under discussion and and the
structures are being built and the
structures are being built in kind of a
flexible way. So that way when the final
conception of everything is kind of
locked down and like this is exactly
what we're going to do. Um then we can
use those structures to very quickly um
put in those details and um and so uh
those things have been happening. Um
Riley has not been um like you know
dismissed or ignored or or not discussed
or not planned for. Um there are just
some elements of um internal external uh
aspects to the the communication. Um,
and so I hear principal principal uh
superintendent Sagura saying that um,
uh, you know, we can, um, you know,
crack that door, uh, but also knowing
that, um, we will continue to be
responsive to any changes that come up
over time.
>> And and we are we are leading um, we're
creating bridge teams to support the
transition um, between any two schools,
any trio of schools. uh Stacia Pascal
who's here in in the front um is leading
that work. Uh and so again, it's we we
want to be intentional. Um we we are we
owe you we will provide more clarity
around what we've done thus far because
I can understand how it feels like it's
been a vacuum.
Where's three? There was a three. Okay.
Sorry.
>> Um we're also a neighborhood family. So,
I'd like to second that the cut off
boundary be first street um and not this
little triangle carved out for airport.
That makes no sense. Um
so to be zonally that might help if
you've had 24 principles that you've
hired in the last year.
>> No, no. when I first got here in 20 22
20 23 24
>> because that we had those types of
vacancies in 22 23 before we all came
together.
>> Okay. So, but this is clearly a program
that works. So, why are we trying to
break this up and how are we different
from Brier Woods in that in that
process?
So um when I talked about the pillars of
the program or the like the goals of the
overall system improvement, you heard me
talk about um wall-to-wall dual
language, right? And
what we know is that the program was
built to ensure that the focus was
emerging bilingual students, but we
believe in access to other students,
which is what has made Richtop so
successful. The reality of it all is
that the number of emerging bilingual
students that are accessing these
programs has continued to decline and
it's and it's declining at a pretty
rapid rate between the uh wall to wall
to language programs. I think we're at
14% 22% 24% and 44%. And it's it's going
in the wrong direction, right? And so
the way that you actually build a
healthy model, right, when it comes to a
balance of emerging bilingual and
non-emergent bilingual students is you
have to ensure that you have access to
the program for those students. And what
we know is we know where our students
live who are emerging bilingual. Um but
we know that they're not accessing
accessing the program. Now, even with
all the hard work, right, we're still at
14%. We're still at 22% 21% and these
are established programs. And here's the
reality. The state of Texas has changed
the law. Our policy and and the way that
we have to respond is going to require
us right in the near future to move the
dual language certified teachers to
where the emerging bilingual students
are. And we are all fighting for these
great educators, us and every school
district around us. And so we're going
to get to a point if we don't make a
change where I'm going to by law be
required to move those educators out. So
I am trying to position the program to
where we don't have to do that because
we have a healthy balance. It aligns
with our policy. It aligns with state
law. Um and and we tackle it that way.
Right now we have 16 um so uh
alternative certification is something
that is not going to be allowed in the
27 28 28 29 school year. Um, right now I
want to say it's 16% maybe 12% of our
educators are on alternative
certifications. So you can imagine there
is we are having a huge staffing
challenge when it comes to staffing dual
language educators and it's only going
to impact this program to a greater
degree because we don't have that
student population to support it
required by law. So, so that's why this
this is different than the than the
balanced enrollment that doesn't have
the programmatic stability question.
That's why I was committed and I'm very
frustrated. I want you to know I am very
upset that I'm having to make this
change timeline wise. Um, but this these
programs the the the plan is still very
much um aligned with who we are. I
evaluated the work. I feel confident in
the work. I need to make adjustments and
refinements, but that is why this has to
happen. Um, not because of something
else. It's it's really a function of the
emerging bilingual students, the
students themselves in the programs and
ensuring that it's viable for years to
come.
>> So, you're trying to harness it out of
the 40% that live in the reside program
instead of the 60% that transfer in.
>> So, so
I say that again. I'm trying to harness
I'm I'm trying to understand
>> 40% here live in the area 60% transfer
in. So you're saying not enough emergent
bilingual will transfer in. So you want
to put it in an area where the home
population will boost those numbers. Cor
>> so so what we know over time is that um
whenever you programs change, we've seen
leadership change, right? we have seen
where something as simple as a
transportation route changes and all of
a sudden the program shifts
significantly. So there are four
wall-to-all language programs. We are
trying to add capacity by making these
moves. We're going to add about 600
seats. Uh and we're also trying to
stabilize the program so that we
collectively get to 50/50. Now it's not
50/50 just in terms of merger bilingual
notion bilingual. It's also 50% in time
in terms of time uh in both languages,
right? All right. And so there you don't
have to be precise, but I want you to
know that it all kind of has to work
together for us to be successful as a
school district. Um, and it's it you're
44% now. And there are school districts
the there are other schools that are 22
and 24% and then 14%.
We're 14 here. We're 14. Yeah. Riley's
44.
>> Yeah. So we're 14 here.
>> But most Yeah. But the majority are
transfers. So there's no way to adjust
that through transfers is what you're
saying instead of disrupting an entire
school of kids. So
So
that's the other it's
we have to ensure access right I I can't
have family families choose to come to
to Richtop right that access these
transfers that is not going to ensure
access to those students the way that I
ensure access is to position the program
and provide transportation
>> I don't know who we're going kind of
going
>> sorry the last the last one I had was
Um, if they were adjusting the
boundaries potentially to 51st Street
for uh Lee, can we also adjust the
middle school boundaries? Because now
this whole community has been kicked out
of the middle school that they were
formerly going to and high school be the
same, but that is not a direct feeder
pattern to go to web and then Macallum.
>> Yeah. So, so in the letter last night,
we talked about, you know, picking that
up in the spring semester after we built
up the academic plan, academic vision
because the boundaries, the feeder
pattern alignments, the thousand other
moves that we're making um are are not
going to go before the the board in this
fall, right? So, I I don't want to speak
to can I change that boundary when it
comes to middle school feeder or high
school feeder. Um the goal was to reduce
the number of splits within our schools
to no more than two, right? That was the
goal that that we had. Right now, like I
said, we have elementary middle schools
that have four or five high schools.
That's not what we want. Um that will
slow down because we have to take a we
have to just approach it um
in in another way to get to where we
need to be. Uh which is why we're going
to pick it up in the spring semester,
progress it, create the time, and then
come back a year from now and take that
vote. So, when it comes to Dolby, I
mean, Dobby is an there's lots of
incredible schools that are doing
incredible things. I I I really get
discouraged when I hear about like, you
know, should I go to this school or this
school? Like, I families are going to do
what's best for their student. I want
that to occur. Um, but there are great
things happening at all schools
regardless of the letter grade that's
been assigned to them. Uh, and there
there are communities that I've had
conversations with just like this at
schools that have three U8 like weight
on them. Um, so that that'll be a
different conversation, but that's when
we'll tackle it.
>> Yeah.
>> And and that's where the splits between
this is and we've been looking at this.
So that's where a split between a
neighborhood and a school is different,
right? Because that's a conflict between
guiding principles. If we want fewer
splits, but then we want to keep
community together, you it's impossible
to have it both ways because in one way
you're going to create a split. other
ways you're going to create multiple. So
that's what we have to work through.
>> Okay. Yeah. I'm sorry I'm like going
along.
>> Um my initial question was going to be
about Riley's staffing which you
addressed. I wanted to make a comment. I
would really encourage you and your
staff to think about how you can provide
additional clarification
um related to the email last night
because how it came across is I think
creating a credibility problem for you.
It comes across like what you are doing
especially related to Breer Woods and to
Maplewood is not in line with your
values.
>> So it's not Yes. And so not to address
necessarily in this room, but I do think
your team needs to think about how you
can provide additional clarification
within whatever you know issues you're
dealing with that you can't disclose. I
think that would be a good thing to do
for the wider community.
>> Appreciate that.
I worked on that letter too to try to
like bring in things that
>> I trust me I do not use chat GPT. Take
that off the record. That's not
something I would ever do.
>> Thank you so much.
>> I'm not good enough for that.
>> Thank you for being here. Of course.
>> Um I just want to say that personally I
understand and appreciate what you're
saying about moving these dual language
programs to the communities that need
them. So, I understand that. I get that.
I think there are a lot of parents that
are part of these programs that
understand that, too. And because of
that, a lot of us are committed to
making that change with our program. But
what I'm concerned about, and
specifically with Pickle, is funding for
Pickle Elementary. So, from the things
that I've read, it sounds like schools
that are under turnaround plans get
additional funding. I also saw an
article talking about middle school
teachers potentially getting additional
stipens for working in these schools
that have the turnaround plans. But from
everything else that I've read specific
to Pickle, even though we think a
significant amount of that population is
going to stay at Pickle, there's not
going to be a turnaround planned
associated with those students, which
means they're not going to the school is
not going to be eligible for additional
funding.
understanding that you are asking our
community to make big decisions and you
are asking the administrators and the
teachers that choose to stay with this
program or become part of this program
to take on a monumental task. Building a
community like Ridgetop and creating
this magic is not something that happens
overnight. It takes time. It takes
commitment and it takes a lot of hard
work by our administrators and our
teachers. And I'm very concerned that
the school is not going to get the
funding it needs to retain the teachers
that bring that commitment to the school
and that it's not going to have the
funding that it needs to build a program
like the one we have at Ridgetop. So if
the school is not eligible for
additional funding because it's not
associated with the turnaround plan,
what is AISD going to do to make up the
difference?
>> Yeah, great question.
So um
I want to be what what we have clearly
articulated in our turnaround plans was
the allocation of funds. It doesn't mean
that we don't have the ability to match
our funds with the plans which is why in
the staffing plans that we released we
said this is the staffing plan for a
programmatic move. This is a staffing
plan for a a consolidation. This is a
staffing plan for a turnaround school.
Uh, and to be clear, um, Pickle, uh,
Wooten, they they are two UAs, right? I
mean, they or one UA, depending on kind
of which way you look at it. Um, and so
our students need the resources like
wherever they are. Um, I am committed if
we have a plan, right? I am going to
resource that plan. Just to be clear,
when it comes to stipens, you know,
those are those are like, you know,
those are very hard to commit to early
on because we're limited in the funds
that we have, which is one of the things
that gentleman over here in the blue
shirt said, like what are the risks that
we're trying to mitigate? And the risk
is budget risk. That is a a real risk
that we're trying to manage. Um, if
there's a plan, I will resource it. I
understand that transitions are going to
occur. What I can't commit to is um like
past you know a transition period a
commitment to continue on at some point
it will stabilize. Uh that's the goal,
right? We cannot continue to apply
resources um you know at at this rate
and not see a response and and then the
school stabilize and then figure out
okay how do we kind of back off to to
allow the resources that we do have to
be enough because if we like right now
right now you know burn and web I mean
the honest truth is we are pouring into
those schools rightly so we need to
that's okay those you know we need to do
that and whatever we agreed to do this
plan um transition plan versus another
transition plan. I will resource it. Uh
and I am cutting everywhere I can. I
mean, I am I am desperately trying to do
that to ensure that the programs are
supported. So, I don't um there's not an
allocation, right? If you're wanting to
say, Matias, where's the $800,000 that's
going to come to the ridgetop pickle?
You know, it it's not done in that way
because it's not a tap. It doesn't have
to be defined that way. What I want to
do is say this is what the ridgetop
community needs in transition. We have
pickle students there who also need
support. This is what needs to be done.
This is what we're going to pay for.
That that plant has to be the the
foundation of the ask, not what we had
to do for the turnaround plans, which is
what you're referencing because that
does have a different level of um
scrutiny is probably the word I would
say. Uh requirements, um compliance. So,
we want to be really clear early on what
that was. So, I just want to be we will
allocate the funds. We're going to agree
to the plan. um I can go back with the
team and and figure out what language
needs to be communicated. Um I don't
want you to leave here and say and think
that it's going to be the same amount. I
don't think that it's something I can be
I'm able to do, but I want to
acknowledge that where our students are
and where the need is is where we need
to put our funds and our resources. So I
I can we can do that. We can do that.
>> We're paying attention to this. I mean
the school district is saying that we're
making
funding in a situation that's
and you're asking us to put in these
changes. They show us that you're going
to
>> Yeah. And here's the thing. I don't want
to What I What I do not want to be a
part of are programs that are not
sustainable. That's the honest truth. I
have programs right now where we get
students that are stranded in them in
year two in a four-year program. Like,
why is that? Well, it's because our
partner dropped out or it's because a
leader changed in the the principal and
the principal or maybe a leader changed
within the school district. Like I I
want to find and support those programs
that we believe in, ensure they're
sustainable and fund them appropriately.
That's what I want to do. So, you're
going to see us and our trustees ask me
all the time, Matias, we've been doing
all these things for the last 20 years.
We got programs everywhere. I can I can
you can go to any school and find like
20 programs. The question is, are those
programs still aligned to our values?
Are they still meeting our student needs
and are they sustainable? Like I would
argue that this is one that is dual
language is for Austin ISD. Like we're
all in. Like I mean we talk about it all
the time. Um but to your point like we
will fund those things that that uh
align with our values and and yes we
have resource challenges but we do have
dollars to pour in to our students and
to our programs. That's where the fun
money should go. It shouldn't go to lots
of other things, but it should go to
those. So, what I can do um is work with
the team to kind of figure out what
would be an appropriate consideration
given where we are in the planning
process because there are things I still
don't know yet about what this could
look like and what each community will
need as they come together. Is that is
that helpful? Because I I mean
>> Yeah. I mean, you're saying that you're
part of the values right now.
That's what we're talking.
>> Yeah. No, it's a great comment. I want
that as well. So, let me let me see what
language I can add.
>> Okay. Um I we've taken a lot from the
front. So um we'll do one, two, three,
four.
>> Oh, I'm good.
I'm usually one of the most quiet people
in this room, but if you know me, I've
been pretty loud. I hope
I just wanted to say that you sir, but I
appreciate you being here. I appreciate
that you have kids
in school district. My mother was a
teacher at DOS. Okay.
>> I got to see what it was like to be in a
rather diverse school at the time to
a more fluent neighborhood
and you know come Friday will be one of
your substitute school nurses. So
>> yes it's awesome. I just wanted I just
want you to know that I think a big part
of this is wanting to know about the
academic academic plan. I feel like
listening to Trusty Hunter and some
other people, you know, on podcast. Yes,
I do that. Um are
that that's that's really what they are
are also wanting to see and so I I hope
so too. Also, yes, I really would like
to know more
about about what was going on with those
other schools and I really have a lot of
faith here. The other thing is, you
know, especially yesterday with our
votes is that not to let you not to let
the district off the hook, we are
watching, but that's also a big part of
why we are in the trouble we're in. And
it's a very long-term thing and it
stinks, but I'm really in it for the
long
education and language. And also, I do
not live in this neighborhood. I had
cousins who played on the top
playground, but
perhaps hearing and so that maybe we can
kind of get into other topics questions.
Maybe perhaps a meeting for those
parents concerned that are going to stay
maybe that could happen so that they
could have more time. It seems like
there's
>> Yeah, thank you for the comments. Um
yeah, I mean you're you're amazing. Um
since your mom was amazing too or is
amazing. Uh and so I I would say um I
think that's a good idea. I think
perhaps splitting up and saying, "Okay,
you know, if we want to create more
space to have a specific conversation
around those families who are interested
in the transition to Riley, have a
different conversation as we continue
with the program at Pickle. I'm more
than happy to adjust and create the
space and have the team here to engage
and begin to build those plans up.
Um there's a lot happening in the state
of Texas and and yes, last night there
it continues to pour on us, right? And
um I I want you to know that, you know,
I am committed to this school district.
I love the school district. Um I want to
do whatever I can to ensure transition
is um done in a very thoughtful way. Uh
what I am anxious about is delaying
important votes. You know, at the end of
the day, you know, there there are still
10 schools like on this list. Um, you
know, and it's hard to say, but
we cannot continue to to just not move
forward. When it comes to academic plan,
ep academic vision, this is something
that gets talked about a lot. And I I
want to always ask when whenever someone
says that, what do they mean? What do
they have? What do they in their mind?
What do they envision as an academic
plan, academic vision? Because about two
years ago, um, we were looking at
building this out. We have an ac we have
a um AISD
um uh strategy. It's kind of academic
strategy. I don't know if y'all knew
this. It was started in 2020. Uh it went
through 2025. It was a list. It had
included a vision. It included a
mission. It included a list of
strategies. None of them were actually
implementable if that's a word. Uh they
were just kind of generalized strategies
that were released. And then the
pandemic happened. Nothing nothing
happened, right? And we worked and
worked and worked. Uh and then in 23 um
we looked at going through and starting
a uh portrait of a graduate. What do we
want out of our students? You know, we
talk about and I I was on the ex podcast
last night and we talked about um
attitude. Like we want students that
advocate for themselves. We want
students that, you know, understand what
it's like to talk to someone who doesn't
look like them. We want students to feel
comfortable in their own skin. We want
these things for our students,
you know, and we also want them to feel
comfortable failing with us because
we're going to pick them up, right? And
we're going to support them and tackle
the next thing and the next thing, but
it needs to be done our way. Well, so
what is our way? You hear us talk about
all the time in Austin IC, we value
librarians. Like I'm not going to be the
superintendent who ever says we are
going to do anything other than support
our librarians and a love for reading.
Problem is the state doesn't pay for
that. Not really. Right. Nurses. We pay
for nurses. That's not something that is
required by law. So I So we have to find
the funds to do it. The one thing that
we don't often talk about is curriculum.
Do y'all know that we spend, you know,
every other year about $8 million on
curriculum that we believe is aligned to
who we are. There are much less
expensive versions out there. And you
can guess which ones those those are. So
we can save $78 million, but I promise
you I would have a room 10 times the
size full of people saying, "Matias,
that's not who we are." And I know that.
And so when I think about the work that
we have ahead, we we do know who we are.
We do know the values that we have
because we protected them along the way.
We protected planning time in high
school. We protected planning time along
the way because that's who we are. Now,
is it codified in one singular document?
No. Do we need to do that? Yes. So um as
we move forward um because I did have a
plan 18 months ago to do a portrait of a
graduate academic vision academic
philosophy and then do the framework to
ensure that all of it got woven into all
of our documents. But at the time we
were tackling tea agreed order. I had
educators like pulled in a thousand
different directions doing tier module
after tier module after tier module. You
know we were going through and building
out multi-ter systems of support so we
understood where our students were. Were
they on grade level or not? what
interventions do we need to apply to
support our students? All that was
happening at the same time and it's all
the same people, you know, that it's the
same people. And so when we started this
work, you know, I trustes and I had a
conversation like, yes, we need to do
this, but we're not starting from an
unknown. It's not like we're we're doing
this without a north star, but we do
need to codify that and understand who
we are. What is our vision around early
literacy? I've made changes already with
early childhood um and and you know we
had adopted behaviors of moving our
strongest educators to third grade
because that's where STAR is. If you're
at third grade, you know, and we have
not built a system that supports our
students in K12,
you know, you are not positioning our
students to be successful. So, we've
created a vision. We changed our
approach. We're focusing on on early
numeracy, early literacy, K12, being
really intentional, developmentally
appropriate material, all everything.
So, we have to like improve the system
so that we're responsive to our student
needs early, not just when they get to
third grade. And then every other
student who's in the system, make sure
we understand where they are, are they
on grade level, are they not, what
interventions need to be applied, do we
have the curriculum to support the
interventions, do we have the people,
which is where content intervention has
come in. And if you do, then all of a
sudden the system begins to respond. And
you're seeing that now. So, um, we're
going to do that work. We're gonna I've
already told our trustees that work will
be led by Dr. Maxwell, our assistant
superintendent of academics K through
12. Um she's an incredible individual
doing incredible things and she's been
here with us. She knows the work. She's
respected and I'm very confident as we
move into the spring semester and this
builds. You will see your values in that
document. We do have documents already
uploaded about kind of the the goal and
the intention, but that effort should be
an 18-month effort. Uh and I that's just
the honest truth. There's been so much
that we've been dealing with. It's been
hard to create the space to focus on the
important because it's been urgent after
urgent after urgent. So that's that's
how we're tackling it as we move
forward. Was there another comment?
>> Oh, thanks. Thanks for the single single
clap. I appreciate
>> um number two.
>> Sill clap is great.
>> All right. Hello. I'm uh Alex Tabada. I
am a mom to three uh little baby
Rattlers and I'm also a fifth grade
teacher.
Um
um I guess like I I have like a billion
things I'd like to say. Um but I think
our as a mother my journey to finding a
school home has been so varied. Um, we
started at Riley, we moved to a charter
school, we came back to AISD to
Brentwood and it was all very
tumultuous. And this is the first um
place that we have felt at ease and
like, oh, these are our people, like,
oh, this is what a good quality school
looks like. Um, oh, I'm starting to
shake. I'm nervous.
>> No, you're doing great. Um,
and I think that there's a lot that um,
you know, there's a lot at stake here. I
I've been following this just like kind
of like a psycho. Like I watch your
YouTube channel and I watch all the
meetings and I go to the Zoom meetings
and
um, it's concerning. My husband is also
a dual language teacher at Lamar Middle
School. He is the department chair
there.
Um, so we share a lot of the same
families.
Um, I'm really really concerned about
how this is going to play out
um for teachers. I don't know that the
staffing plan.
This is according to what the Becker
principal said at the meeting a teachers
market
and we are being treated as AISD
employees. I get my paycheck from AISD
but I am a ridgetop employee
and you are closing my school. I do not
know where I will work come next school
year. And the reality is that
if we're going to represent Ridgetop and
we are going to represent Pickle, there
are not enough spaces for everybody
there. And if we are going to represent
Ridgetop at Riley
and represent Riley at Riley, our
community is getting broken apart. And
that is the reality.
And parents need to know that reality.
And also
a little tiny little asterric is that so
much of my enjoyment working here is
that I bike down a bike highway three
miles to school and back with a second
grader and a third grader and we did it
all year last year. And I tried I said,
"Okay, let's bike to pickle." We woke up
on Saturday morning. We tried to cross
I35 and I was like, "Here I am." like
this is crazy pants. Like people are
looking at me like what is that lady
doing with those three kids? And that's
where our new home is. And it's like I
can swallow that pill, but I cannot
swallow the pill of like tell me we're
all going to pickle and tell me that
when the numbers don't come out how you
are expecting them to that you are not
going to level and send me across town
because I'm an AISD employee because
that impacts me and that impacts my
children.
So, um, thank you. Thank you for just
being you. I mean, I I appreciate you,
you know, sharing your time that you've
given here.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, that's good. I think that it is
imperative that you include the teacher
voice in some of these meetings
and I
would love to be part of that committee.
There needs to be a representation of
schools, teachers from schools that are
being impacted and how are we going to
feel comfortable? How what needs to be
considered because it's a teachers
market.
Um, so you watch all the meetings,
you're watching Becker. Uh, love that
tattoo.
So, um, my first comment in response is
if anybody believes that we as an
administration or the trustees do not
understand
how incredibly important our educators
are. Um I I need to to check how I
communicate because everything that
we've done since the moment we came
together was tried to strive for
balance, try to attract educators and
professionals into the workplace. Um
increasing compensation, you know, being
very thoughtful when it comes to
leveling, you do based on the
allocations, we would have done so much
more of it. We are protecting schools as
best we can and only when it becomes at
a point where it just doesn't make I
just can't make it work. Do we make the
adjustment? You don't see those
meetings. I know that many of our
families don't. But Brandy Hosak,
myself, Lisha Drinks, the chief of
staff, we sit there and go school by
school. Katrina Montgomery here, who's
the CFO, she I mean I'm here to call her
out, but I love calling her out. um we
we sit down and and I I'm balancing the
impact of the school given the number of
students that we have and always trying
to be really thoughtful that that
educator in that space is someone that
we care for and someone that we
absolutely have to have. Um I've been
really intentional about how we support
our educators. I've been really clear
about what we're going to do and how
we're going to do it. You're right, the
intentionality and the detail of the
plan should have teacher voice. Um, I
know that Brandy Hosac and the team
talent strategy um, either have or are
going to meet with all staff. I'm not
sure if that's happened already. I can
find out. May have going through just
like I'm going through all the schools.
They're coming back and meeting with all
staff specifically. I'll find out when
that is if it hasn't occurred on how
we'll figure it out right now. Um, and
so we want to make sure that that you
are supported and and we there's going
to be a survey to hear your voice
because there are other teachers that
have different perspectives that want
different things. And so all of that has
to be considered in this work. Um, but I
can commit to you to ensuring that
there's teacher voice in the plan.
That's my expectation. That's what we
plan to do. Um, and then the meeting
where talent strategy comes speaks
directly to staff without, you know,
everybody together. Um I'll find out
when that is but that is a commitment
and we we are doing that for sure
because I want to make sure that voice
is directly kind of brought into the
process through that means not just in a
larger meeting
>> I believe that
>> okay so so it sounds like we need to
come back out perhaps I don't know how
many were attended but we can we can we
can figure that out for sure yeah and
and just to be clear like you know are
the number of educators who I will also
say yes it I Travis used those words. I
love our teachers. Like my my mom was a
teacher here for 42 years. Like I love
our AIC teachers. Like I I I just I want
to protect our educators because they
are professionals and without them
nothing will happen in this school
system. Um and I also want to be like
really clear like I I will do everything
I can but it's not going to be perfect
for every person. It just isn't. There
are desires that educators have and
you're you're right. There could become
a point where you're blending two
schools and we're just there's more
teachers than we than we need to have at
that campus. Well, that's why by process
I would want this to be the next and
then this and and use teacher voice to
understand where that educator wants to
be and then use the authority I have to
ensure they have a place. Um, the only
way I would say that you're, and I would
never say this, but like you're an
employee of AISD, is if at the way end,
>> if you don't find a home and it doesn't
match, then I will find a home for you
that works as best as I can make it
work. Um, that's my commitment because I
don't want you ever to leave Austin ISD.
Uh, that's just, you know, the honest
truth and that's why we're not hiring
anybody outside until April.
>> I don't know who is next. Victoria, you
got me?
>> Here I am.
Okay,
>> good morning. Thank you. Thank you for
being here. Um
my question and you you've spoken um to
it a little bit earlier, but um I'd like
to have some clarity about the specifics
of the problem that
is being solved by closing down Richto
and moving us over there, right? Like I
am so proud and impressed by how our
community has been responsive to the
idea that you know there are students
that need this program right and we want
to be close to them but um
there's a question of how thoughtful
have we been in
um preparing for those changes and
designing them and um how uh how pressed
for time are we? Right. So um you spoke
about changes in Texas law that are
relevant to this and might be relevant
to our timeline. I would like you to
maybe elaborate on that and and more
than that I would like to better
understand um what your vision for dual
language is. Um
here's a thought when we talk about
Richard has 40% of emergent bilingual
because we're using
>> you have 14%
>> 14 yes yes sorry uh 14
>> very yeah
>> yes um we're using the term emerging
bilingual in a certain way and we
we moved from uh a previous designation
which was English language learners and
I think there were even more porative
ones previously and we moved to this
term emerging bilingual because we
decided that um being bilingual is an
asset that the Spanish language you know
it's it's something that we appreciate
as a community and um that we don't want
to think in terms of deficit of what you
don't have you're not English proficient
but the way the law gives this
designation to students actually is
you're deficient you don't know English
proficiently enough. I have students in
my classroom, we all do, that
are bilingual in particular ways. They
have one parent at home that speaks
Spanish. They also have a parent at home
that speaks English and they have a
right to um a bilingual education and
our district's policies to appreciate
that asset they're coming in with. And
um
ultimately every student at this school
is an emergent bilingual because we are
all going through the experience of what
it's like to be out of our comfort zone
linguistically and be with people that
are different than us that speak a
different language at home. I am all for
having more students that speak Spanish
at home that need to build that uh
English language, but like I would
really like a specific of your vision
and how it aligns with those values and
not necessarily the values um that use
emerging bilingual is a euphemism for
just like tracking other things. Um
right. So what's what are the specific
problems that we're facing? Is it
pressure about the program and its
sustainability? Is it scores
um in standardized tests that are low
for students that are labeled as
emerging bilingual but actually have to
do maybe with other factors that
undermine their academic performance?
like I would like really specific
information so I I can trust that this
big disruptive move is something that I
can just fully trust and and move over.
I'm willing but I want to know.
>> Thank you.
>> Yeah. So
um so I'll start and then Avette uh is
our um multillegal education uh leader
and so I'll have her kind of chime in.
So I want to be really clear the way the
state defines it is is how I have to
respond just to be clear like I don't we
get to embrace and expand but at the end
of the day when it comes to how our
students are um coded and I'm going to
use coded because it's something we have
to do. We submit each student uh in our
system. It's called the PIN system and
we identify uh you know what student is
receiving which supports and which
programming and students receiving
special education services students
receiving that are emergent bilingual
like the list goes on and on and on. So
really be clear when I say that that's
why I'm using that word because there
are funds associated with emergent
bilingual and and dual language
programming. If the um emerging
bilingual student is um defined in a
certain way, not AISD defining, it's the
way the state defines. You probably know
this, but I think it's for everybody
awareness that we need to be really
clear. It's not Matias saying this. Um
when you talk about the problems we're
trying to solve, I want to find
solutions
um that address multiple things
simultaneously. We have 116 schools.
This is one of 116
I have to think about the 70,000
students and also be very responsive to
the students that are here at Richtop
Riley, etc. And so the problems we're
trying to solve, we need to reduce the
number of empty seats in Austin ISD.
It's the honest truth. We need to reduce
our reliance on spaces that are
incredibly expensive to operate.
Portables. Portables are meant to be
short-term solutions. They are. We have
portables in district that are 50, 60,
70 years old. The newest portable I
think is 32 years old. They're they're
exposed to the environment on all sides.
And so long term, because we're in the
forever business, 5, 10, 15 years, 20
years, even you know, now we're spending
an incredible amount of resources that
should go to compensation, that should
go to programming on very expensive
spaces. So through all these ideas and
all the planning and all the work the
goal was to remove the number of seats
which is consolidations which is one of
the things that is addressed as part of
the richtop move. It is to stabilize
programming because the law that you I'm
referring to is the law that was passed
in the 89th legislature that says that
every student in a school district must
have a certified teacher. If you have
emergent bilingual students identified
by the state, not by Matias, I am
required by law and it's based in but in
2728 it'll be kind of full K through
five that I provide that allocation. So
if you do not have that allocation,
where do you think I have to take it
from? Somewhere else in the school
system where we don't have the number of
emerging bilingual students as coded by
the state. So if we find ourselves at
richtop in the near future with 10 14 n
20% I'm going to be required forced to
remove the allocations and place them
elsewhere which means a stipend right
will not be there and so I'm
anticipating that I I I want to get
ahead of it. We never want to be
reactive. We want to be responsive. So
this move allows you to increase the
number of students who have access to
the program which will increase your
emerging bilingual student population.
We have 14%. We'd like to move towards
40%. It'll reduce help reduce the number
of seats in Austin ISD. We have 20,000.
We need to remove that. It'll help
reduce the number of really expensive
spaces that we operate and support every
single day. We have over 450 portables.
We had 600 at one point. Those have to
come down. They're short-term solutions.
At the end of the day, like all these
have to occur. I'm accountability in
this situation isn't necessarily a
driving factor for this specific move
because I feel very strongly that Pickle
and Wooten are both moving in the right
direction. evidence of it. So, I don't
want anybody to leave here saying, "Oh,
we're making this move to ensure that
somehow we break accountability chain."
They're going to break it regardless.
Um, but those are the three driving
factors. The back one would be just
ensuring that um we have a a program
that's closer to the students who are
identified as emerging bilingual. I
don't know, you want to add anything to
that.
>> Okay. But those are the three driving
factors and kind of the fourth one for
this specific move.
>> Okay. But what does it need to happen
this year?
>> Yeah. So, so I want to be really honest.
Um, those who have been following along,
we have a humongous budget deficit. We
do um this is not something I like we
like to share very often, but our cash
flow, right, is very very low. What most
people don't realize is that we depend
on our cash every year to pay payroll
right from July, August, September,
October. In November and into December,
what do we start to get? We start to get
tax revenue from all of you all and
everybody else paying their property
taxes.
Now, if we do not improve our fund
balance, we get to a place where we
cannot make payroll. If we continue to
have a deficit budget, you eat into that
fund balance that protects you on the
cash flow side. I don't know if that
makes any sense, but really like you
have our savings account. We draw down
our savings account until we get paid by
t property taxes. That's kind of how it
works. If you continue to run deficit
budgets, which is what we're trying to
do as part of this plan, right? reduce
our overall cost, then you erode your
deficit budget, making it more likely
that you will go negative and not be
able to make payroll in November,
December, right? Which impacts you,
which impacts all of us. The last thing
we're ever going to do is is be at a
point where we don't make payroll. Now,
I'm at a point now where we can make
hard decisions and we can get ahead of
it. I can get ahead of the um
allocations by the state that I have to
respond to for teacher certifications. I
can get ahead of stabilizing emerging
bilingual student populations. But that
takes time. If I wait a year, deficit's
going to get bigger. The risk of not
making payroll gets bigger. The the
you're one year closer to having to be
fully compliant with the law. Like
that's what all this is. And what I need
is time for our families to plan. Time
for us to work together to actually be
successful in supporting our students.
The last thing that can happen is us
make a change late and us not be
prepared to receive your students. So
that is what is driving this. I I don't
know if you want to say I that's fine if
you don't have to.
>> Yeah.
>> Hi.
>> Um so a lot of my questions have kind of
been answered right now but I so I just
want to make it quick to give someone
else um opportunity but just reiterate
um that we chose Rich specifically
because it is a small campus and a
wall-to-wall dual language. um
objectively bilingual education is
beneficial to academic success um and
lifelong success honestly and having
this small likeminded community is is
part of that magic. Um, with that said,
um, you know, I I keep hearing that
transitioning to pickle is for the
greater good and I can wrap my head
around that and about the long-term
planning. So, like I understand all of
that and at the same time, my reality
right now is that my kids are in school
right now. So, I guess my ask is more as
more details come out, as more plans
come out, um I think specifics are
really important because um I have a
hard time honestly trusting. I don't
feel like a guarantee that this move
isn't going to negatively affect my kids
in the short term. That they aren't just
like some like I don't know if this is
probably not the best like AI like
they're not just like the sacrificial
like kids right now. Um and like I
understand the greater good. I
understand long-term effect and like I I
understand all of that. Um but this is
also my reality. Um, and so I just want
to know that their needs are going to be
met. And I think the way that I would
have more confidence in that is by just
having a lot more specifics.
>> Yep.
>> Um, as things roll out because right now
I just don't feel that.
>> Yeah, that's a great comment and I so
thank you for sharing that and I think
that's that's what makes this so hard. I
mean I
it makes it very very hard because it's
your child. Um and
and that's that's everything. I mean I
you know like I mean I it's everything.
My kids went to Sunset Valley, right?
And and I I I am very much attached to
that school. Um and I have to
acknowledge that um this is your this is
your family. There will be a disruption.
The only way I can help and improve that
is to plan together. Like that's the
honest truth. I have to get these
communities together and plan, plan,
plan, build it out, commit to it, and
you will have my commitment to ensure
it's implemented. That's what I I
believe that I we do in this
administration better than previous. We
execute. Um we have evidence of that. I
you can look at the outcomes. You can
look at the tag read order. The list
goes on and on. I will execute, but I
need the plan to be developed with
community. If I came to you with a plan
right now, it would not have your voice.
It would not have Pickle's voice. It
would not have teacher voice because
we're not at that point. We have created
the structure for it. We had the teams
in place. But if if I gave you a plan, I
know it wouldn't meet your student
needs. That's the honest truth. So the
goal is to, you know, adhere to the
timeline, get to the vote, move forward
with a plan, hire the principal, and
build out the best plan to ensure that
that disruption, which is real, and that
pain that you're going to feel is real,
is mitigated to the best of our
abilities. That is that is how this
could work. If I wait until the spring
semester and take a vote, then all the
time, all the education, and our ability
to execute starting, you know, in the
summer and into this the fall semester
of 2627 will be lost. and you'll be even
more frustrated with me. You'll be
furious. I I would suspect because I did
not I was not able to support your
student. Um and so that that's why this
time matters. And so uh that's what we
intend to do. That's what we're
committed to do. That's how we're set up
to do it. So if we get through the vote,
that's what will occur.
>> And I just wanted to also say that you
know my kids here
are part of the
only
>> Oh, that's awesome.
Where are you from?
>> Oh, awesome.
>> And so, um, but you know, if you ask
them, they know about everything that's
happening and they say, "Well, the
teachers, where are the teachers going?"
And you know, they one of my first
graders said today, "I can make new
friends anywhere." I want to know where
the I want to know where the teachers
are going. All three of them love their
teachers so much. The work that is being
done here is so special. And so, just to
have that disrupted
and I just hope that more.
>> Yeah. No, thank you for sharing that.
>> All right. Thank you guys so much. We
are at or past time. That bill was just
for attendance to remind the teachers
for funding. So, we have we're on
attendance. Um, I want to say thank you
to Superintendent Sigura and all of the
team. Um, I want to say thank you to all
of you who are here that are Rattlers
and non-rattlers. Um, your your input
and your questions are really important
and um, they're going to be hanging out
here for a little bit. If you would like
to hang out, we're going to start lunch
duty in about an hour. So, feel free to
go get an actual badge and stay um
because we always need help with that.
Um, also, if you're part of the
community, we are selling gratitude
lunch tickets in the morning and it's
cash only.
All right, thank you so much everybody.
Um, uh, if you are a member of the AISD
staff who can continue to engage for a
few minutes, if you would raise your
hands, um, that'd be great. And so you
can kind of see who is, um, here. Thank
you very much.